[Musique]
bonsoir a tous très heureux de vous
retrouver pour cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec tv 78 nous
sommes le lundi 17 décembre tout de
suite les titres de se situer durandal
un mois tout juste aujourd'hui qui a été
lancé le mouvement des gilet jaune et en
raison de la hausse des prix des
carburants la contestation s'est élargie
à nombre de revendications citoyennes
alors que l'acte 5 de la mobilisation a
rassemblé moins de monde qu'à l'est la
suite en plateau avec moi alain boucher
gilet jaune habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines et noël c'est dans une
semaine et si vous êtes toujours en
recherche d'idées pour offrir pourquoi
ne pas vous tourner vers le local
plusieurs possibilités de cadeaux
inventé ou fabriqués dans les yvelines
existe c'est notre fil rouge de la
semaine premier focus ce soir sur de la
bière produite à bois d'arcy et enfin
d'édition les principaux résultats
sportifs du week end avec du football
notamment avant la trêve cette victoire
importante trappe s'impose à domicile
contre rennes malmaison et prend la tête
de son groupe de régionale 3 j'accueille
sur ce plateau mon premier invité à
l'embouché bonsoir bonsoir gilet jaune
habitants à 50 ans ni vous vous êtes
engagés depuis le début du mouvement
dans ce mouvement de gilet jaune alors
ça fait aujourd'hui un mois jour pour
jour précisément qui a été lancé cette
contestation des gilets jaunes néant au
début en réponse à la hausse sur le prix
des carburants ça c'est bien sûr a
étendu sa s'est étendu à d'autres
revendications va parler de la suite du
mouvement dans un instant une réaction
déjà ce week end dans la mobilisation
n'a vu apparaître de nombreux panneaux
avec la mention rick ce référendum
d'initiative citoyenne ce matin chez nos
confrères des échos
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
affirmé ne pas être contre l'idée du
rics est un bon sujet de débat que nous
allons organiser partout en france
dit-il est ce que ça c'est une avancée
réelle
à bas les ja ça veut dire qu'il nous a
entendus parce qu'effectivement c'est un
point essentiel
on a remarqué qu'il y avait un manque de
démocratie notamment de démocratie
citoyenne
et il s'est avéré qu'on a vraiment pu
confiance dans nos hommes politiques
tous partis confondus
ça fait trop longtemps qu'on nous enfume
ça fait bon ça n'est pas dû seulement à
gouvernement macro ont baissé plus des
plus anciens c'est plus anciens mais
sauf que on a l'impression que le
gouvernement macron il en remet une
couche sérieusement donc sur les sur les
manifestations sur les lieux de
rassemblement des gilets jaunes
on s'est aperçu qu'on avait une force et
même une force politique
donc maintenant on va réfléchir à la
suite des mouvements et figure
effectivement le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne parce qu'on voudrait retrouver
un peu plus de deux voix de la part des
citoyens on précise juste que ça
permettrait effectivement aux citoyens
sous réserve d'un nombre de signatures
suffisantes pouvoir par exemple approuvé
d approuver un texte de loi voté par le
parlement c'est aussi proposer des lois
c'est vraiment une démocratie
participative est tout à fait alors non
seulement ça peut être effectivement
révocatoire abrogatoire notamment et
moyennant effectivement un certain
nombre de signatures pour déclencher
comme ça existe d'ailleurs dans d'autres
pays notamment la suisse où il y à des
référendums et que je sache là c'est la
suisse n'est pas un pays archaïque
quand vous faites partie aussi dans un
groupe de réflexion à ce que ça pourrait
aller plus loin par exemple mettre en
place des des élections à la mi mandat
emmanuel macron qui se représenterait à
mi mandat devant devant les citoyens
français pour valider ou désapprouver
son mandat eh bien écoutez quand vous
parler d'élections à mi-mandat c'est
existe aux états unis par exemple
pourquoi pas nous pour l'instant nous
sommes dans un groupe de réflexion pour
savoir quelle est la suite à donner donc
ça peut être effectivement une autre
forme d'élection je pense que notamment
qu' une dose de proportionnelle
significative pour les élections
législatives
ça irait certainement dans le bon sens
alors dans un entretien aux échos
edouard philippe a également détaillé
quelques annonces faites la semaine
dernière par le président de la
république
emmanuel macron notamment la promesse de
gain d'un gain de 100 euros pour les
salariés proches du smic
cette hausse sera effectué l'a précisé
edouard fillias une augmentation massive
de la prime d'activité qui sera versée
dès le 5 février 5 millions de foyers
français sont éligibles à cette mesure
est ce que le compte y est alain boucher
pas d'engouement du tout parce que dans
les 100 euros il ya déjà la réduction
d'un certain nombre de charges sociales
qui ont commencé au mois d'octobre donc
à savoir sur un sur un salaire au smic
c'est de l'ordre ont entre 20 et 25
euros à peu près mais ça ça ne s'est
déjà en déduction c'est dire qu'on n'est
déjà plus qu'à 75 euros
ensuite c'est une prime et une prime
peut être remise en cause à tout moment
donc on préférerait bien que je sois
artisans donc que j'emploie des
personnes on préférerait quand même
qu'ils aient une hausse du smic
directement ne pas passer mais parce que
la laouve losc est extrêmement dangereux
dans toute forme de primes c'est qu'on
devient dépendant de ce qu'ils veulent
bien nous la donner c'est donc là à
savoir le gouvernement
donc on justement on en a marre de cette
dépendance
on veut beaucoup plus d'autonomie et les
personnes je peux vous affirmer que sur
les ronds-points nous disent la chose
suivante on veut vivre décemment de
notre salaire en gros c'est ça
voilà sur les autres mesures le
président de la république avait annoncé
notamment la fin des heures les heures
supplémentaires pendant défiscaliser la
suppression de la hausse de la csg pour
les foyers les plus modestes saucisses
assez with les premières ça vous
rappelle quelqu'un nicolas sarkozy entre
autres
ça a été supprimée par françois hollande
pour des raisons purement politiciennes
faut pas se leurrer donc là je pense
qu'on va enfin dans le bon sens donc
c'est une mesurette si vous voulez nez
qui peut permettre de d'augmenter
effectivement les revenus est ce cet
ensemble de mesures edouard philippe a
précisé qu'il a cool très 10 milliards
d'euros à peu près et que il a demandé
aux entreprises d'être me vise à
contribuer l'or et justement il ya deux
choses
ça ne coûte pas 10 milliards d'euros
parce que tout cela c'est vous le
contester bien sûr et je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce qu'en fin de compte la
les gilets jaunes se sont retrouvés des
économistes qui démontre que les 10
milliards d'euros on peut les trouver
sans toucher au budget en fin de compte
on est un des pays les plus mal gérées
d'europe à cause de la technocratie
enfin bon on va pas faire le procès de
tous les technocrates mais il ya un de
l'argent qui est franchement dilapidés
dans ce pays donc les 10 milliards on en
trouve même en faisant très attention
sur le plan de la gestion on trouve pas
10 milliards mais 20 milliards d'euros
donc on peut très bien redit ce tribut
et 10 milliards sans aucun problème pour
augmenter le pouvoir d'achat notamment
du coup alain bouchon il disait tout à
l'heure ça fait un mois que les jeunes
se sont mobilisés la contestation a
permis de faire au moins le fléchir le
gouvernement sur certains sujets du coup
quel bilan premier bilan vous vous tirez
de c'est un mois de mobilisations à ce
que c'est plutôt positif négatif non ça
peut pas être négatif ça va de soi parce
que de toute façon il ya des petits
acquis le compte n'y est pas mais par
contre ça fait réfléchir à une chose à
savoir que s'il n'y avait pas eu cette
mobilisation
on en serait au point de départ d'il ya
un mois ou deux mois donc on a fait
bouger les lignes
je pense qu'à un moment donné
le gouvernement eut un petit peu un peu
chaud aux fesses etc ce manhwa de
s'extraire de cette expression est donc
ça nous a renforcés
ça nous a renforcés dans nos convictions
de se dire enfin le peuple peut avoir
une influence sur la politique est ce
qu'il ya une forme de lassitude dans vos
rangs ou au contraire vous êtes plus
plus motivé que jamais non mais il ya
deux choses que vous avez remarqué qu on
approche des fêtes de fin d'année il
fait très froid notamment le week-end
dernier
donc c'est pas une lassitude et c'est
simplement peut-être que des personnes
souhaitent passer un peu momentanément à
autre chose mais je peux vous garantir
que la comment dirais-je
on sera encore plus motivé que jamais
peut-être dès le printemps au début du
printemps
parce que justement on aura eu
l'occasion de s'organiser de se
structurer de faire des propositions
et là je dis franchement au gouvernement
fait attention je crois que ça ça va
repartir peut-être encore plus fort que
la l'automne donc la suite peut être au
printemps 2010 9 la suite à donner vous
disiez vous interrogez en ce moment sur
quelles suites à donner
il faut continuer d'aller se mobilisent
à paris ou au contraire faire des
actions partout en france et le barrage
devant le dépôt de carburant de
coignières dans les yvelines cciv des
actions de toute façon on a très bien
compris aussi sur la stratégie qui était
amené cette stratégie c'est de ne pas
faire toujours la même chose
en fin de compte il faut un peu baladé
nos forces de l'ordre
et puis paris c'est symbolique mais en
fin de compte ce n'est pas toute la
france or le mouvement des gilets jaunes
ça concerne toute la france c'est pour
ça aussi que des grandes villes ont été
assez fortement mobilisés et je pense
que ça va continuer dans ce sens-là des
gilet jaune appelle d'ores et déjà un
acte aussi ce samedi prochain il faut
qu'un acte aussi selon vous bah écoutez
moi je vais pas parler au nom des autres
gilet jaune un ça va de soi disons que
notre rôle pour ceux qui ont un petit
peu d'espacé dans les médias c'est
d'essayer d'orienter malgré tout n'est
la faute des gilets jaunes sait aussi
que chaque citoyen soit très libre en
fin de compte c'est ça aussi
donc on ne demande pas à la personne qui
vient nous rejoindre sur les
ronds-points d'où elle vient
on lui demande pas sa couleur politique
la seule chose qu'on lui demande c'est
quelle est ta souffrance et on l'a
compris peut-être un regain de
mobilisation au printemps 2009 c'est ce
que vous espérez merci alain boucher est
de passer sur ce plateau gilet jaune et
et vous êtes habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines merci dans l'actualité
ces travaux doivent permettre de
désengorger l'axé au niveau de
rambouillet le chantier d'élargissement
de la nationale 10 prend du retard les
véhicules pourront circuler sur deux
voies dans le sens paris-province
seulement en juin à 2019 contre janvier
annoncée initialement les raisons la
découverte d'un câble électrique haute
tension et l'état de la chaussée plus
dégradés que prévu a prévu pardon
ajoutez à cela est la viabilité
hivernale qui va interrompre les travaux
de janvier à mars 35 mille usagers
circulent chaque jour sur la nationale
10 on reste à rambouillet ou ingéniérie
vient d'inaugurer ses nouveaux locaux
rue félix-faure l' agence départementale
à des deux communes rurales et des
ménages de versailles pour être au plus
près du terrain dans le sud yvelines
elle accompagne les zones rurales dans
leurs projets de matières en matière de
bâtiment de voirie d'urbanisme et aussi
de sauvegarde du patrimoine 166 communes
yvelinois sur 185 et trois
intercommunalités
elles sont adhérentes d'ingéniérie comme
chaque mois le dossier de la rédaction à
quelques jours de noël nous avons choisi
de vous donner à quelques idées cadeaux
pas n'importe lesquels des cadeaux made
in yvelines inventé pensée ou tout
simplement fabriqués dans le département
pour le premier
zoom ce soir marylène yapi chez nous
nous fait découvrir une marque de bière
à consommer bien sûr avec modération
elle créée par trois amis d'enfance à
bois d'arcy pour fabriquer sa bière tout
commence avec une céréale le malt
c'est vraiment ce qui va donner à notre
base de céréales ce qui va donner la
couleur de notre bière ce qui va donner
le profil gustatif de notre de notre
bière et au final c'est aussi ce qui va
créer du sucre ou ce qui va nous créer
ce que va nous créer chez au club pour
hooking la brasserie artisanale monté
par une bande de trois copains à bois
d'arcy il ya trois ans on utilise un
panel d'une quinzaine de malte
différents qui sont concassés dans ce
moule un faucon a sélectionné notre
notre grand con la concassée
l'idée c'est de faire venir tout le
grain qu'on a stocké là bas jusqu'à
cette cuve ici qui est notre cube
d'empotage
donc c'est ici où on va réellement
brasser les graines sont mélangés à de
l'eau chaude à 65 degrés celsius pendant
une heure et demie lorsque l'infusion
est terminée le rinçage commence pour
s'assurer que tous les grains soit entré
en contact avec le liquide avant de
passer à l'émulation après filtration
une fois qu'on a notre note liquide qui
est rentré en ébullition on va commencer
à faire nos premiers houblonnage sachant
que les houblons plus on va les utiliser
tôt pendant cette ébullition et plus ils
vont donner de l'amertume après avoir
brillé pendant une heure et demie le
liquide est stérile et il faut utiliser
un refroidisseur pour faire baisser sa
température
une fois qu'on l'a refroidi on vient
positionner matheny kid à l'intérieur de
ces de ces cubes que vous avez derrière
derrière moi qu'ils sont des fermenteurs
et une fois tout notre note liquide a
été refroidie qu'il est rentré à
l'intérieur de ces cubes à 20 degrés on
va ainsi miné la bière c'est à dire
qu'on va lui
ajoutez des levures les levures agit
cependant cette étape de fermentation
leur travail de manger le sucre créé
l'alcool et le co2 qui rendra la pierre
pétillante l'accusent passe ensuite de
20 à 0 degrés pour la dernière étape de
garde au froid l'otan bobo pour
fabriquer une bière on va avoir une
journée de fabrication une semaine de
fermentation et 3 semaines 2
deux gardes qui fait une cuve allaient
monopoliser pendant à peu près un mois
une fois qu'elle a été
qualité brasser chez o clock le brassage
se fait deux à trois fois par semaine en
fonction des cuves disponible pour
varier les plaisirs
les 3 brasseurs développe aussi une
gamme de bières vieilli en barriques
pour nous l'idée c'est pas d'acheter des
barriques neuves c'est d'acheter des
barriques qui ont déjà servi qui ont
déjà une histoire et de profiter de
l'histoire de ces barriques et 6 ont
stocké 40 baril qui vont faire leur
travail pendant six mois a un nom pour
des bières aux arrière-goût d'alcool
plus fort les bières o'clock sont
distribués dans des bars et des
revendeurs indépendants en france et en
europe mais aussi dans leurs propres
boutiques avec une gamme de 12 à 15 bien
différentes qui varie chaque semaine la
première année on était même un peu
surpris que la bière était réellement
quelque chose qu'on pouvait qu'on
pouvait offrir à noël cette année ils
ont même développé un calendrier de
l'avent et une gamme à offrir et nous ce
qu'on propose pour pour noël c'est un
petit pack de un petit pack de bières de
avec six bouteilles dans lequel vous
avez les cinq best seller de la
brasserie qui est complété par notre
part notre bière de noël note christmas
day
et qui emballée dans un paquet cadeau
avec le descriptif de toutes nos de tout
nos biens
la france est le troisième pays européen
en nombre de brasseries derrière
l'allemagne et le royaume uni il ne
reste plus que huit jours au père noël
pour remplir sa hotte de cadeaux si les
indétrônables lego playmobil ont leur
place cette année encore sous le sapin
les jeux de société figurent également
sur la liste des enfants et direction
rambouillet pour découvrir ces tendances
2018 avec aurélien oms dernière ligne
droite pour les cadeaux de noël dans
cette enseigne spécialisée à rambouillet
les jeux de société sont toujours autant
plébiscité et tendance cette année
seront notamment en lien avec le petit
écran ou encore avec l'actualité
littéraire et cinématographique en fête
cette année les 20 ans de la sortie du
livre harry potter est également la
sortie des animaux fantastiques numéro 2
est sorti au cinéma récemment ce qui
fait qu'on a une forte demande sur les
produits et de toute la gamme harry
potter donc que ce soit les lego les
figurines articulées tous les produits
dérivés les traditionnels lego et
playmobil auront également leur place
sous le sapin tout comme les poupées
surprise lol et hachey molle ou encore
les loisirs créatifs
nous on a deux filles donc c'est
principalement des poupées les petits
chiens et puis on essaie de nous est un
petit peu en reprend les rollers et
protections aux nationaux fourchette de
200 euros à peu près pour tout le monde
donc on est bien
premier poste de dépenses les cadeaux de
noël représenteront en moyenne cette
année 340 euros des dépenses anticipées
pour deux français sur trois qui en
majorité respecte à la lettre les
souhaits des enfants
on est encore sur du découpage de
catalogue où les enfants vont faire leur
liste et effectivement ça va être le qui
vont être à l'origine de la demande et
la fille sa liste donc d'après la liste
ben on partagera ma fille et moi chaque
français prévoient en moyenne d'acheter
plus de 8 cadeaux pas de doute la hotte
du père noël risquent encore d'être bien
remplie cette année et on pouvait y
trouver des idées cadeaux villepreux
organisé samedi son marché de noël avec
une vingtaine d'exposants artisans et
créateurs et l'équipe municipale a
souhaité partager ce moment de
convivialité avec les habitants un
retour avec nicolas landry et au rayon
puis important que les années
précédentes le marché de noël de
villepreux a mis l'accent sur
l'artisanat vingt exposants venus pour
la plupart des yvelines ont présenté
leurs créations devant un public conquis
tout est fait main et en pièces uniques
ça c'est important c'est à dire que là
la visite est la cliente elle peut se
dire il ya que moi qui ait ce produit et
là j'ai craqué effectivement j'ai acheté
une petite pochette en toile de jouy
très jolie qui est emballé déjà mais
avec en plus que des pièces artisanales
unique
donc c'est plus agréable que dans la
grande distribution
un rendez vous important également pour
l'équipe municipale qui profite de ce
moment pour échanger avec les habitants
depuis 2008 on vient sur le marché de
manière très régulière pour rencontrer
les gens qui habitent ici c'est un
moment qu'on aime bien parce que les
gens viennent nous voir viennent nous
viens nous pas nous parler on se
retrouve ensemble avec tous les élus on
est une véritable équipe c'est aussi ça
notre force à villepreux des animations
pour toute la famille ont permis aux
plus jeunes de patienter le tabac nous
détendre le panneau avant l'arrivée dans
quelques jours du célèbre bonhomme à la
barbe blanche
il est connu pour ses contes de perrault
animé le château de breteuil également
ne fait pas l'impasse sur noël la
demeure de choisel séparer de ses
guirlandes et est prête à recevoir ses
visiteurs pour les vacances qui débutent
à la fin de la semaine marylène yapi
chinois à visiter pour nous le château
dès le jardin on comprend que c'est noël
au château de bouteilles pour découvrir
l'ensemble des décorations
jean-emmanuel chars aux administrateurs
de la demeure nous la fait visiter
le circuit sera décoré dans cette
ambiance festive jusqu'à la fin des
vacances de noël
c'est un travail de plus de 15 jours
réalisée par lydie paillis de la
jardinière et pour la da silva
l'intendant dans la salle à manger du
personnel du château
l'ambiance qui reconstituait s'est
déroulé en mai 1905 lorsque le roi
edouard vii d'angleterre est venu
déjeuner au château
son chauffeur est reçu à table par le
personnel qui leur soient dignement
on a en plus évidemment l'a fait les
décors de noël avec ce magnifique sapin
est un thème ou juste cette année d'un
salle du château sont proposés à la
visite et reconstitue son histoire et
donc c'est l'ambiance début de siècle
début xxème siècle qui reconstituent et
la maîtresse de maison sa jolie robe est
descendu superviser les derniers
préparatifs pour le déjeuner donné ses
consignes aux chefs cuisiniers quand on
monte les étages on arrive dans les
pièces des propriétaires avec une table
de noël aux curieuses invité sur ton
rouge qui côtoie barbe-bleue et le
prince charmant cendrillon ou le marquis
de carabas ce qui est maîtresse cette
année une robe de réveillon dans le
salon de musique créée à partir de
branches de sapin mais très content de
cette nouveauté on espère comme ça crée
une nouvelle robe chaque année à partir
de 2018 chaque personnage du château a
droit à son décor spécial les chats
bottés qui sont la mascotte du château
d'idron autre que l'on retrouve un peu
partout dans un circuit de la visite ici
dans la bibliothèque vous avez le chat
libre et son élève et qui sont très bien
entouré d'un magnifique village de noël
si sapins sont répartis tout au long de
la visite le plus somptueux étant
réservé à la grande galerie hommes sont
dans la grande galerie du château où il
ya les plus grands portraits de famille
et puis certains portraits royaux effet
dans cette pièce que nous avons mis le
plus grand sapin
il fait 4 mètres cinquante de hauteur et
puis de l'autre côté de la cheminée le
père noël est un fauteuil attendent les
visiteurs qui veulent se faire prendre
en photo la visite du château se fait
tous les après midi et pour les vacances
scolaires à 15h30
[Musique]
et c'est déjà sa dernière chronique
sport de l'année bonsoir nickel et demi
d'euros et oui le temps passe vite et le
temps passe vite alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi nos petits rendez vous
depuis le début de la saison chaque
lundi vous venez sur ce plateau pour
présenter lé principaux résultats du
week-end vous nous emmenez ou pour
commencer alors direction trappe
aujourd'hui un peu moins de 20 minutes
de nos studios ce dimanche 16 décembre
en match en retard du championnat de
régionale 3 les trappistes se sont
imposés dans des conditions climatiques
difficiles à domicile contre rueil
malmaison score final 1 à 0 un score qui
suffit à leur bonheur on écoute
l'entraîneur de l'équipe richard vase et
redit au micro de notre journaliste
nicolas d'andré sentiment de victoire
logique et méritée
comme si on aurait pu se rendre le match
beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas su
concrétiser nos temps forts on a une
équipe d'euros et qui nous a pas mal
embêter on a su faire le dos rond on n'a
pas su profiter des espaces qui nous
offrait
par rapport au rapport de force mais on
voit la finalité c'est que on a su être
solides ne pas prendre de but et qu'on
termine meilleure défense du championnat
a lancé michael c'est important de
gagner mais est-ce que elle revêt une
importance particulière cette victoire
de trappes pour lui évidemment mais je
la tiens vous le savez bien en tout cas
chaque match compte et en particulier
celui là avec cette victoire les
trappistes reste invaincu et reprennent
la première place de la poule c de
régionale 3 avec un petit point d'avancé
sur boulogne billancourt le podium
l'objectif fixé en début de saison
semble de plus en plus accessible
l'objectif il est il est toujours le
même on est des compétiteurs et même si
normal que le président ils soient
tranquilles ils modèrent il tempère les
joueurs nous on n'a qu'un objectif c'est
de sets gagnés de gagner de gagner tous
les week-ends et de rendre à la fois le
staff tous les gens autour les
supporters qui viennent nombreux fiers
de nous et voilà c'est la première phase
aller aussi pour eux en 2019 les
trappistes tenteront de garder cette
dynamique après la trêve hivernale pour
conserver la première place les joueurs
dit chardy se rendront sur le terrain
des mureaux le dimanche 20 janvier et
oui ça fait tard leur résolution
prolonger leur série d'invincibilité qui
affiche actuellement dix matches sans
défaite du rugby à présent dans quelle
direction le championnat d'honneur je
peux rien vous cacher à grégory thil
mort dans l'âme l'informel versailles
n'en finit plus de gagner comme trappe
en football les versailles et sont
toujours invaincus leurs victimes du
jour le skiff les joueurs de la cité
royale envahir balayé cette équipe sur
le score de 40 à 3 avec cette victoire
les bleus conservent la première place
avec 42 points huit de plus que leur
dauphin montesson leur bilan est parfait
avant la trêve 9 victoires en 9 matches
disputés chien on continue à parler du
championnat honneur mais cette fois-ci
de la poule 2 le sky rugby a sorti un
gros match ce week-end en s'imposant à
domicile contre ministère finance sur le
score de 34 à 11 de son côté cheuvreux
s'impose 11 à 7 à l'extérieur face à
vitry au classement les saint quentinois
conserve la sixième place du championnat
avec 20 points et chevreuse est deuxième
avec 32 points en neuf journées
merci michael on vous retrouve dans
votre émission de 7,8 sport je vois vous
êtes venus d'ailleurs avec un trophée en
plateau c'est pas pour moi une petite
coupe ne pas pourvoir désole un grégory
nous remettrons notamment le trophée
tant convoité de sportifs évinois de
l'année dans le 7-8 sport la coupe du
courrier juste là mais je ne vous en dis
pas plus 5
c'est un revoit c'est à voir suspense
reste entier juste après ce journal
michael avant ce programme sportif il
faut bien sûr pas d'avoir le ventre vide
je vous propose un brunch michael enfin
un brunch créatif le concept était
organisé pour la première fois au prisme
d'elancourt ce week-end à côté du repas
une découverte des artistes programmés
dans la salle ce dimanche c'était avec
la compagnie la main de l'homme manon
varaldo et mélanie poquet
[Musique]
avec human aubeterre clément d'azun
s'interroge sur la répétition du
mouvement sur l'engagement physique au
travail
il raconte à travers le jonglage un art
qu'il a choisi de partager avec un de
ces artistes de plateau avec la main
comme si elle à l arrivée par
l'initiation on a fait un peu de
foulards pour apprendre à jongler à
trois foulards on a fait un peu de
déquilibre d'objets ça veut dire
apprendre à tenir un objet en équilibre
donc là on a fait des plumes de paon
parce que c'est assez simple vous des
templiers au jonglage et et
s'amuser sa musique pour ça dans cette
discipline initier des gens qui
connaissent pas du tout cet atelier
s'inscrit dans une nouveauté celle des
brunchs créatif lancé cette saison par
la salle du prisme ça fait partie des
choses qui sont importantes dans un
théâtre il faut être en mouvement il
faut imaginer de nouveaux moyens pour
aller à la rencontre des publics en
douce et ont des changes de partage et
de convivialité pour sortir un petit peu
du rapport traditionnel du spectacle de
rencontrer aussi d'autres personnes ça
quand on vient un spectacle c'est pas
toujours le moment propice pour échanger
avec son voisin de fauteuils voilà
pendant la la représentation la la c'est
le propos c'est de créer recréer du lien
et du coup là le poignet plus tôt mais
plutôt comme ça un autre rendez vous est
prévu pour le mois de mai avant de
devenir trimestriel la saison prochaine
[Musique]
c'est la fin du set 8 journal belle
soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]